awesome
[Music]
guys we are actually coming up on one of
the most popular habitats here at the
zoo our chimp have attacked we have one
champ named Amy she is gonna have a baby
[Music]
morning champion
coming to look at that new baby
so excited about this baby coming aren't
you oh yeah
super stoked I hope we have another girl
uh yeah I think I've been team girl like
this entire time this morning Sarah
Jenny and myself we need to make sure
that the chimp habitat's nice and clean
for them to have their breakfast I'm
gonna make sure their food is spread out
far and wide
since Amy is a low ranking chimp and
she's pregnant I want to make sure that
she has access to plenty of food Champs
live in troops and alpha male oversees
everything with Amy being low ranking a
lot of the higher ranking chimps will
steal her food
Amy give me a bit
[Music]
how are you baby
being pregnant we want to make sure that
she is gaining the weight that she needs
to gain
let's release the chips
[Music]
keeper Campbell to keep away
we are ready for chips
[Music]
The Chimps they all get really excited
to go out onto the habitat
they have so many choices if they want
to get away from people they can
disappear behind a hill if they want to
be up close and personal they can do
that
we've got a climbing structure so the
chimps can get up really high
that's so cool it's wide open up to the
sky so they can just look up and feel
like they're free
so there's lamps and there's Dakota
Genie's sitting there on the tree hi G
beans
John's way of pie
see lots of chimps but I don't see Amy
anywhere
she's missing out on a lot of breakfast
right now
I'm about to stop by
right now I'm heading over to see Amy
who's due with baby any day now it's
pretty important that we get this
ultrasound done to make sure that the
baby's healthy
one of the things I love about the North
Carolina Zoo is there is no normal day
I may be in the grasslands in the
morning to look at a rhino
but I can get three or four calls while
I'm out there to go look at Lane polar
bear
I can be all over this place and it's a
big part
[Music]
she you ready to go she is all ready
so um Amy's been doing really good so
far with the ultrasound hopefully we can
locate this baby pretty quickly
[Music]
hi Amy how you doing look what I got for
you I got this for oh is that your belly
thank you you want that oh
yes
let me see your arm oh you're a good boy
what's that Gus is Amy's five-year-old
son we're hoping he's gonna be a good
big brother what are you doing huh
okay Amy you ready dear are you ready to
show me that baby oh it's a good bill
she's showing me her belly already she's
ready
I've been working with Amy the past six
months on her ultrasound okay let's do
this
she has to have trust in me and trust
that what I'm doing is okay and that
she's gonna get a really nice reward
piece of Apple you got it
we shared 98 of our DNA with them so you
could say that they are 98 human she's
so patient she's so smart I feel like
I'm looking at a person
I'm not supposed to say this but she is
probably one of my favorites
okay Amy you ready dear
[Music]
see your belly oh it's a good bill I
know come here gonna do this we'll see
your belly
she's obviously feeling a little bit of
anxiety
can I put this on you really
she may not want to do this I am a
little worried I want to make sure that
the baby is still looking pretty healthy
in there
we're gonna potentially have to come up
with a plan B
I can kind of direct you and she may
just trust you a little bit more
we take baby steps and she can leave
anytime she wants
uh you're just going to get it as close
as much as possible
good girl is your belly girl good girl
Amy there you go
angle it that way a little bit
the script girl Lanes
all right now
aim this way there's no touch
good girl Amy how's that
oh perfect okay
we're getting really really good images
you're doing so good Amy now we can
watch the image that we just took
hopefully we have a healthy baby
so the head is this way all of this is
spine right here okay this is an arm I'm
glad you know what you're looking at
there's our heartbeat right there
seeing a baby that you've been waiting
on for the past seven months is actually
kind of indescribable that is a really
strong chimpanzee heart that is I mean
she is beating really really nicely so
she's she's growing well so got a got a
good sized kid in there yes a baby is
looking awesome hearing him say that
makes me feel like I've accomplished
like this huge goal that Amy and I have
both been working towards for six months
good job awesome job
and human care gyms tend to give birth
fairly quick during the nighttime hours
we have no idea when it's going to
happen
we're all just waiting to just come in
and there'll be a baby
[Music]
guys this is fall here at the North
Carolina Zoo
[Music]
foreign
oh the black bears one thing I can tell
you a hundred percent about the black
bears is how much they absolutely love
honey
I put some on this tree over here
so I'm just drizzling some honey they
love sweet stuff
[Music]
a bear in the wild is going to spend a
majority of its time wandering around
looking for food so we're trying to
recreate that for them we're trying to
think like what would be challenging for
them
we want them to work for it I like to
put some of the produce out on some of
the bushes so they have to get their
noses up off the ground like a big
jigsaw puzzle we make for the bear all
right that's good
today we're going to be giving the honey
to Nova and Luna and their sisters
he's coming he's coming
[Music]
Nova Luna have different personalities
they're very smart Luna's a little more
you know on the crazy side she's high
energy she's always getting into things
got it moving that log oh she found all
your honey
Nova is super chill she just likes to
hang out and have a good time
what is Nova doing oh my gosh the side
foreign
[Music]
best day ever
it's a shame we can't let Holly out yeah
I'm gonna go check on her
I hope she's all right
we have three black bears here
hey Holly
is 28. she's an older bear
she is a sweetheart we refer to her as
Princess bear because she's very
particular about her food
we noticed some changes in her behavior
we gave her a bone the other day and she
didn't really eat it usually tears right
into it she's also not opening her mouth
I started getting a little worried so I
put in a call to the vet hospital and
JB's gonna come have a look at her
hey guys hey how are we doing
a little concerned we offered her her
bone in here and she didn't touch it and
that's not normal for her okay
what's up what are you doing here
see how she's got a lot of saliva right
there is that normal for her for I guess
last couple weeks has become more okay
she's had a like a ball of foam
basically forming I'm gonna see if we
can swab some of that saliva out of her
way
this is not good there's a mask
like right on the left
so that could be causing a little bit of
the pain she has a little growth not
sure what it is at this point probably
within the next four or five days we'll
get her under anesthesia and get a
really close look at her
okay thank you guys yeah thank you
thanks Ashley
we're not really sure what it is so it's
a little bit concerning she's an older
bear and we care a lot about her she's
really sweet it would be very difficult
to lose her it would be pretty
heartbreaking so we're hoping for the
best outcome for sure
[Music]
thank you
good morning
let's go over here big guy
[Music]
I'm hearing some odd noises
okay is somebody fighting is somebody
unhappy
oh
there's a little bit of blood on the
floor
what's going on
[Music]
I just got into work I'm hearing some
odd noises okay is somebody fighting is
somebody unhappy
oh
there's a little bit of blood on the
floor
what's going on
oh
my goodness oh you've got a baby honey
[Music]
Amy just gave birth
she is about two weeks early but these
things happen on their own time frame
oh what a sweet baby
Amy's got the baby in her arms and you
could tell that she's just a doting
mother the two of them are just so
bonded already
[Music]
oh my goodness
we'll have to go call the vet so they
can get a good look at those and I have
to go tell all my co-workers
I'm gonna call Christy
[Applause]
oh my gosh she's gonna be so excited
hello can you hear me yes we've got some
big news what's up
Amy had a baby
say oh my gosh she is doing such a great
job she's got the baby all cleaned up
she's good Mama
we will
for a girl we do have quite a few boys I
got my fingers crossed for a girl
[Music]
[Applause]
hi nandy
[Music]
it's over here
[Applause]
you see who's watching us don't you
yeah the work's coming immediately but
just beautiful impressive animals I take
care of these animals all the time so I
really am attached to them
they are threatened in the wild because
of the habitat loss and the poaching
they are on SPC survival plan to ensure
that their population grows to a healthy
number see the tight little group down
there the one standing out kind of in
front I think is Briggs
Briggs is our male breeding ports
you need to move him to another Zoo so
he can continue to breed it could be
vital to the survival of the species
I'll miss Briggs he's been a good guy
capturing Briggs will be difficult
because these oryx are nervous and they
will run if you get too close to them
the only way we're going to get that
oryx off of the habitat is to
anesthetize him with the dark gun
we're cutting material to camouflage an
area for the vet to hide behind they see
movement they'll Bolt
it could be anything it could be a
veterinarian could be a lion it could be
a leopard are you ready for another one
yep all right oh
when he takes a shot he will lay flat on
the ground and shoot out through there
let me go ahead and add these last
pieces
real good yeah if I
[Music]
if I would
we're gonna prep here we're just outside
of the grand size habitat it works about
several hundred yards away from us but
they got really really good hearing
that's why we're keeping our voices down
Briggs is leaving us he's going to
another zoo I don't like darted animals
but it's the only way we can get Briggs
off the habitat
you're very quiet everybody's dance
until it's over we're all kind of bits
and needles
get your fancy pants on I'm gonna put on
a ghillie suit it's basically like a
camouflage Swamp Man outfit
it's hard to wear it's a sweat box
but the animals you can't see me because
I'm the veterinarian
I'm the bad guy I'll have my radio off
while we wait for them to get closer
I'll just hope for the best
do this
JB the fat ass headed out there with the
normal morning truck
[Music]
they'll put food out from the orange
foreign
hopefully the Orcs won't notice
okay we're good all right yep
if he gets a successful hit
call us and we'll rush out there
we have effectively smuggled JD in and
he should be hiding like a quiet Bush
waiting for the Orcs
at this point I become the surroundings
I'm quiet
try not to breathe too loudly
we're trying to keep the routine as
normal as possible so we don't tip off
the Orcs
back here and put more hay out and try
to look normal
[Music]
there's a herd of Greater kudu looking
at me
they're barking every other animal out
there is gonna know if something's going
on
[Music]
there's a herd of Greater kudu looking
at me they're barking
chase you gotta get them out of here
10-4 I'm on it
conclude you are already giving it away
they are kind of like the guard dogs of
the plane we need them out of the way so
that they don't tip off the Orcs
okay they're gonna blow my cover
try to move the kodu up here
[Music]
I think we got here just in time
yeah
kind of a mental game that's who pull
this off they should be good poker
players
right now the plan is to move the oryx
towards the North End
brings just crossing the road and headed
towards Sublime
I can't imagine the pressure JB is under
right now
we don't want that animal getting hurt
there's a lot riding on his one shot
there's always a risk anytime we do this
that animal can die
I've picked out Briggs the only shot
that I've got is in the chest and
there's a lot of dangerous parts right
there the lungs there the heart's there
I'm waiting for him to turn sideways
he's taken a step
he's showing me a little bit of his
right shoulder
this is it this is the money shot
[Music]
make sure he's safe
you can actually see him right now
[Music]
all right he's down
he's in the Vets care right now I trust
these guys
so he's down on the ground right now uh
so it means that the drugs are are
taking effect
I'm going to get out just stay back
Briggs is a really big animal he's
probably about 550 pounds he tries to
get up just get out of the way he is
three foot swords on his head if he
Swings with that head I'm going to be
stabbed I don't want that to happen
I know buddy I know
so the blindfold is there to decrease
stimulation so that Briggs stays under
anesthesia there is a clock ticking
those drugs only last so long
okay let's get him set up we need to
stabilize Briggs get him off the habitat
quickly before he wakes up breaks out
and hurts either himself or one of my
team this allows us to give him oxygen
into his lungs
okay give me a breath
perfect he's breathing
he's waking up let me see some ketamine
he's down
the drugs are working
okay let's get him on the move one two
and three okay take him up going up
[Music]
foreign
okay we're leaving I'm just really happy
we got him
now he gets to go to his new home and
he's starting a whole new breeding
program
[Music]
right here okay
within minutes is going to start
recovering
hopefully he just stands right back up
sometimes
great job guys so for the next two weeks
Briggs is going to be inside of this
stall and then we're going to ship him
up to another zoo in Ohio to be a
breeder Bowl
it's vital that we got this done because
Briggs is going to be able to help
increase the Orcs population for years
to come
he's going to help save his species
[Music]
have a nice day at the zoo guys
[Applause]
hello guys
I will be working with diesel today
good boy diesel is one of our
five-year-old male California sea lions
he is a lot of fun
[Music]
you want to make sure that the animals
are staying mentally stimulated
and physically fit as well
it's one of the ways that they can
actually get away from their predators
out in the wild
him to move different parts of his body
can build up muscle
he's a great dance partner he really is
they really enjoy training
[Music]
they love spending time with us they're
very social animals
buddy
[Music]
I got a really awesome phone call that
Amy had her baby
we have been waiting on this baby for
seven months I'm super excited to
finally get to meet this little one
it means doing a great job because if we
have a healthy population we're gonna
have babies
good morning how are you good how are
you good uh I heard our little little
one little one scroll and tush
I guess so
this morning I got a picture of our
newest edition I saw the little babies
swollen butt my first concern was it
might not be pooping it could mean that
the baby's a little dehydrated the clip
that I saw the little picture it does
look a little poopy uh you think she'll
let me see it
okay let's go take a peek
hi Amy
we've prepped up some juice bottles and
a nutritional shake once she sees that
hopefully she'll come right over
[Music]
come here come here I'll say hello to
you yeah sit right here
all right
was
what I don't know I can't really see
Amy's got her baby all wrapped up nice
like a good mother does
you don't want us to see it
actually if you can get her to come up
okay
come on Amy can you come up here
she's allowing us to give her a little
bit of juice but what she's not allowing
us to do is see the kids so I'm working
with Christy here to shift her around
can you come up here real quick
I promise you can have the whole thing
every time we can get Amy to move I can
get a little bit of a view of the baby
I see some cute ears
baby in her arms it is so darn cute
come on up here
[Music]
all right
okay
I'm just catching a little small
glimpses of the butt but again the more
Christy gets her to move around for me
the more I get oh there it is there's
the butt
I think the swelling is not as bad as
the picture made it out to be baby looks
okay the baby's bum looks pretty good
it's mildly swollen but it's not
something that I'm so worried about and
Amy looks like I do Amy looks awesome
that is a huge relief to know that both
Amy and baby are doing great you hoping
for a girl
the last time well we'll know soon
enough you ready yeah
okay you can see your rectum look right
below that
definitely got a little girl
we do
if there's a penis in there I can't find
it it's a cute little girl oh yeah
I am beyond happy I I don't even know
what are the words to use right now
yeah it was great telling Christy that
it was a girl you can see Christy's face
almost light up good job Amy she's
pretty excited she's been wanting a girl
since we've been talking about having
this kid here
but Amy looks great so at this point
she's clear to go out on habitat I'm
proud to do what I do I can't imagine
doing anything else The Chimps are my
life
foreign
[Music]
that's a great spot by the way
so the Rhinos love mud
[Music]
hey Miss Olivia
Stacy and I are getting ready to give
Olivia a mud bath
at 51 she's one of the oldest rhinos in
North America
wild rhinos would live into their 40s
so 51 is impressive got some good
Carolina red clay
a little hard for her to get in and out
of the wallow on her own it's very
similar to you know a 90 year old
grandma trying to get in and out of the
tub by herself
they don't teach you this your first day
on the job
but you just gotta mix it up just
perfect
it's like making icing for a cake
you ready old girl
sometimes this ends up being a mud bath
for the keepers too
it's like being a kid again I like
playing in mud puddles and now I get
paid to do it
pretty good time for the both of us
next to eating mud is their favorite
thing
keeps their skin from drying out it kind
of acts as a sunscreen
um it keeps the insects off of them and
so this is just like a big spa day
their back is more exposed so it needs
to be thicker and rougher but in their
armpits is like baby soft those smooth
spots are actually some of their
favorite places to be touched you can
tell that she really likes it because of
her reactions
I think it's fun
when you're 51 years old you get what
you want huh look
so that's it mud bath complete
you ready
come on we're all done
[Music]
yeah
come on girl
Olivia
I thought when I got here like these
animals don't have any personality but
you realize they're all hysterical
and Olivia makes me laugh the most
hello
that's a good girl
are you coming or just your horn
there you go I've been working with
Olivia for over seven years it's a huge
bond that you form with them I know I
know I want her to be around with me
forever but she's an old lady
whenever that time comes to where she
can't do Olivia things anymore then
it'll be a tough tough conversation to
have but I mean that's part of this job
[Music]
you go I'll paint it up for a couple
days
[Music]
there you go
open
the girl
[Music]
Holly has a mass in her upper right side
of her mouth
she wasn't eating things like she
normally would be we're not really sure
what it is so we will be doing an
anesthetic procedure today one two and
three
[Music]
okay platter in
with older animals I always have in the
back of my mind the worst possible
outcome you get a little nervous we
don't know for sure what's going on
until we get into the hospital but I'll
be next to Holly the whole time
[Music]
on the gurney
we're just going to do a quick
assessment
okay perfect
check her heart rate check her breathing
blood pressure hooked up PCGS hooked up
heart rate of 88
good
good we got it look at that mouth see
where the issue is because this is what
we got called down to look at
it's swollen that is not right
does look like a mask
JB noticed something in the back of her
mouth I'm getting a little worried
so cancer is on the list some type of
infection it could be an old fracture
it's not good not for an animal of this
age
the next step is we're going to shoot
some X-rays of the skull and we're going
to try to figure out where exactly this
is coming from and maybe what's going on
[Music]
Claire Claire
this is not good
if you can look right here
she definitely has a large Mass
this mass is starting to eat into bone
which is preventing her from opening her
mouth
first thing that comes to mind it could
be cancer
it's not good because she's 28 years old
that is really really old for a black
bear I want to get all the people that
are involved in Holly's life together
Aaron the curator is here Chris he's
here Alexis is here I gotta talk to them
about some of the options but it's not
good
it's much more extensive than we've
really wanted it to be
20 year old bear with a six month old
Mass there's nothing we can do to fix it
and it's going to get bigger bigger so
put in her through intensive treatment
for a couple more months is really just
not going to be fair to her my
recommendation is we euthanize Holland
today
when JB mentioned euthanizing her it
hits you motions hit you
um
but I trust him I know he's doing what's
best for colleague
she's lived a really really good life
with us my final gift as a veterinarian
is saying I'm going to help you go
peacefully
it's nice that she can go surrounded by
people that love her
I'm tearing up because I I know how much
she means to everybody else and it's
hard
so never gets easy but it's the right
thing to do so we just do it
it's nice that they let us be here and
feel like we can comfort her
we'll give you guys a few minutes
right now we're giving the keepers and
the Animal Care staff just a little bit
of time
we're at the end so allowing them just
to say goodbye to their their friend
you fall in love with him and having to
let go and Say Goodbye is is very
difficult the last few moments are
definitely the hardest you kind of just
are in your own bubble
you're just thinking about experiences
you've had with her
all those memories are flooding through
your head
[Music]
give her the best and you know she had a
good life
[Music]
she's at peace
there's no pain
she's in a better place so
that's right let me give her a honey
this morning absolutely
[Music]
foreign
y actually had her baby just a little
while ago and you will have the time of
your life watching that baby play on
habitat
today is the first day that the baby is
going to be out on habitat with Mom
I'm really excited because this will be
baby's first time seeing the world
we're gonna go up by our feeding area
where we throw them snacks in get a
really good look at her
all right
with Amy being a low ranking champ
we do worry about the boys being a
little rough with her
she's gonna have to take extra special
care of that baby
[Music]
have you seen Amy
where's Amy
right by the window oh
[Applause]
[Music]
I love you
today is the first day that the baby is
going to be out on habitat with Mom
where's Amy
have you seen Amy
I can see Amy way over there right by
the window
oh you must oh
I was not expecting her to be right up
here oh look hello sweet baby girl she's
the untie here out here it's crazy to me
how just a few weeks ago it was just
this tiny little heartbeat on an
ultrasound and now we have a real baby
out here on the habitat oh my gosh
everybody just wants to be near her
Amy's getting groomed that's a really
good sign
it's really great to see all of the
adult males being so gentle with her and
the baby
she's being such a good Mama
when looking at the baby is hard not to
make a lot of really cute noises because
we're all very excited oh look at this
little hand s
she's so cute
welcome to the chimp habitat baby girl
I think the public is surprised and
excited to see the new baby they're like
kind of looking at it like what's going
on and then all of a sudden it's like oh
that's a baby hey guys my name is
Christy I'm one of the chimp Keepers
here our youngest is just a few days old
and it's a baby girl she doesn't have a
name yet Amy is being the mom we all
knew she would be now it's the hard part
we all have to decide on a name for the
new baby girl
I really like Beverly
oh
[Laughter]
fine
[Music]
do you know termite Mounds in Africa can
be the size of this truck
go hey knick-knack knickknack doesn't
moonwalk
[Music]
today's the day Briggs is gonna make his
final move so we're gonna load them up
and then send them off to Ohio
we're using his instincts to do this as
quick as possible
it's the safest way to get him on the
trailer
[Music]
therefore nice job everybody all right
that was pretty smooth
I am sad to see Briggs go but he is part
of the bigger plan
he will be going elsewhere to breed and
help save the orc species yeah I have
four females so he'll probably be pretty
happy
there goes Briggs have fun in your new
home make some more babies
[Music]
folks one thing that you'll find you go
through the whole circle of life here at
this Zoo
you'll see animals come and go
we experience births we experience
deaths it's part of life you learn to
deal with it
Heather brought by Holly's Prince oh my
goodness
she has tiny little feet they're really
beautiful she's a really sweet bear we
really miss her
but you know you've got other animals to
care for and you remember the ones that
you lose and you miss them but you
continue that cycle
side
[Music]
you just keep doing your job
yeah I just finished up at Rocky Coast
can you give me like 10 minutes before I
get to you
get the North Carolina Zoo there are
definitely sad days there's a heart on
my staff there's a heart on me but then
there are days when you get that call
that there was a baby chimp born
those are the days that make us smile
those are the days that keep us going
the keepers picked a bunch of really
really good names so I'm really excited
to see what they're going to be
it is my pleasure and my honor to unveil
and announce the name of our newest
chimp so on behalf of the state of North
Carolina I give you
[Music]
[Applause]
it was a really good feeling to see my
name on the board
it's Swahili for life
these are our keepers
[Music]
working in a zoo
it's moments like this where it makes
everything worth it
[Music]
Asha is just the perfect way to
celebrate life
[Music]